shuri castle is one of Okinawa's
best-known tourist spots and had earned
World Heritage status in 2000 the fire
broke out in the main buildings before
dawn and the flames spreading quickly
through the ancient Timbers more than 10
fire engines were sent to tackle the
blaze but there was little they could do
local people looking on helplessly the
full extent of the damage was revealed
at first light many of the buildings
reduced to smoking ruins the castle
dates from the Ryukyu Kingdom which
spanned 450 years until Okinawa was
annexed by Japan in the 19th century as
a symbol of the islands heritage it had
in recent days been holding an annual
festival recreating rituals from the
past Okinawa's loss will be felt by
Japan as a whole the guy isn't oh I
understand shuri castle a World Heritage
Site is an extremely important symbol of
Okinawa I feel my heart ache I extend my
heartfelt sympathy to the people of
Okinawa the castle had been wrecked and
restored before from fierce fighting
between US and Japanese forces at the
end of World War two the government has
promised to rebuild it once more Rob
mcbride al-jazeera